Here are some more numbers written in scientific notation. Thinking about what
you know about exponents, try to figure out which of these quantities matches
each of these distances. You might want to think about the order of the sizes
in each list to figure this out. Here are the numbers that are your options.
1.5 times 10 to the 11th meters, 2.4 times 10 to the 22nd meters, 1.7 times 10
to the 1st meters, 8.8 times 10 to the 5th meters, and 2 times 10 to the
negative 4th meters. Each of these matches one of these distances and here are
those distances. The distance from the earth to the sun, the height of a human,
the distance from San Francisco, California to Paris, France, the distance to
the Milky Way's nearest neighboring galaxy Andromeda, and the size of an ant.
Now, just in case you didn't know, a meter is a little bit shorter than a yard.
It's about the length from your nose to your fingertip if you hold your arm out
sideways.